hey this is pressure Locker mr. Lars and
his wife mrs. Lars went to a meet-up and
met four other married couples some
people shook hands with each other but
no person show cans with his or her
spouse and no person shook his or her
own hand mr. Lars then asked each person
including his wife how many distinct
people did you shake hands with each
person answered honestly and
surprisingly each person gave a
different answer how many distinct
people did mrs. Lars shake hands with
and how many distinct people did mr.
Lars shake hands with this seems like
it's impossible to solve but amazingly
this puzzle contains just enough
information can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
let's start with a simpler case where
the meetup has only one other couple for
a total of four people no person shakes
hands with his or her own spouse and no
one shakes hands with him or herself so
the maximum anyone can shake hands with
is two people because each person can
shake hands with zero one or two people
now suppose mr. Lars asked three other
people and heard three different answers
that would be in each person gave one of
the three possible answers therefore
some person shook hands with two people
this would be everyone else excluding
that person's spouse as everyone else
but the spouse shakes at least one hand
the only person who could shake hands
with zero people is the spouse this
means the people who answer to two and
zero
a married couple there is an unpaired
answer of one and that must be for mrs.
Lars
so that means mr. Lars how many hands
did he shake well he shook hands with
the person who answered - because that
person shook hands with everyone else
excluding that person spouse he did not
shake hands with his wife and he could
not shake hands with the person who
answered zero so he also shook hands
with one person
so mrs. Lars and mr. Lars each shook one
hand we can consider this problem
graphically we have four different
points representing the four people
let's label the other people a and a
prime someone shook hands with two
people will draw an edge if two people
shook hands now suppose mrs. Lars answer
to that would mean mrs. Lars was
connected to both a and a prime but this
is an impossible situation because
someone answered 0 in this case everyone
answers at least one so it cannot be
that mrs. Lars is the one who answered -
it has to be someone from the other
couple so let's suppose that a shook
hands with two people since a cannot
shake hands with his or her own spouse
that will mean a shook hands with both
mr. and mrs. Lars consequently that
would mean a prime has to be the person
who answered 0 we can then conclude that
mrs. Lars is the one who answered 1 and
we can also see that mr. Lars has one
edge so that means he shook hands with
exactly one person as well this is a
graphical illustration of the logic just
presented in the last slide so now let's
tackle the original problem with 4 other
couples the meetup has 10 total people
and each person can shake all the 2
people's hands
because they cannot shake their own
spouses hands and they cannot shake
their own hand so each person can shake
hands between zero and eight people
since mr. Lars asked nine other people
and heard nine different answers each
person gave one of these nine possible
answers that means some person shook
hands with eight people that would mean
everyone else in the group excluding
that person spouse as everyone else in
the group but the spouse shakes hands
with at least one person the only person
who could shake hands with zero people
is the spouse therefore the people who
answered eight and zero are a married
couple now we also know some person
shook hands with seven people that would
mean everyone else excluding the spouse
and the person who answered zero now
everyone else but the spouse and the
person who answered zero now must shake
at least two hands so the only person
who could shake hands with exactly one
person is the spouse this means the
people who answered seven and one are
also a married couple we can continue
this logic to show that the answers of
six and two belonged to a married couple
as are the answers of five and three
this leaves an unpaired answer of four
which then must be for mrs. Lars
consequently we can also conclude that
mr. Lars also shook hands with four
people this will be the people who
answered eight seven six and five we can
also see the solution graphically we'll
draw 10 different points to represent
all the 10 people who are at the meet oh
we have mr. and mrs. Lars and then for
the other couples will mark a and a
prime B and B prime C and C Prime and D
and D Prime now someone in the group
show cans with eight people as before
this can't be mrs. Lars
that would mean everyone else in the
group shook hands with at least one
person and we know someone gave the
answer zero so suppose someone in the
other couples shook hands with eight
people will say that a shook eight
different hands now a is not able to
shake hands with the spouse of a so the
only way this can happen is if a is
connected to all eight of the other
points the only person who is not
connected would be a-prime and that
would mean a prime shook zero hands now
someone else in the group shook hands
with seven people let's suppose this
would be B B already shook hands with a
and now we're going to draw out six
other connecting edges now everyone else
in the group is connected to at least
two handshakes so who could possibly be
the person who answered one the only
possibility will be B prime because
that's the only point which has exactly
one edge coming out of it now someone
else answered six hands and let's say
that C we need to drop four more edges
from this point as you can see from the
diagram now everyone else in the group
is shaking hands with at least three
people so who could be shaking hands
with exactly two people that would be C
Prime we now have one more case to
consider where someone is shaking five
hands and we'll say that's D so we'll
need to draw two more edges now everyone
else that we haven't considered the
shakin at least four hands so who could
have shaken exactly three hands the only
possibility will be D prime we now get
to mr. and mrs. Lars
we can see the one answer of four
exactly corresponds to mrs. Lars and you
can count the number of edges from mr.
Lars to see that he also shook four
hands so this is the graphical way that
we could see the solution to this puzzle
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch your own
social media app prashant worker and if
you liked this video please check out my
books there are links in the video
description